Joe Budden is starting his presidential
campaign with two things most other
candidates do not have a lead in many
polls and perhaps because of that the
second thing a nickname from the
president who calls him sleepy Joe some
fellow Democrats are already criticizing
the former vice president for meeting
with big-money donors on his first day
ed O'Keefe is covering the 20/20
campaign heed good morning good morning
John those presidential contenders are
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren who
are calling out the former VP for taking
big-money donations in addition to
trying to quickly raise cash Biden is
largely looking past Warren Sanders and
the other twenty Democrats and directly
taking on president Trump Merrick is
coming back like we used to be ethical
straight tell him the truth
in aviator glasses the former vice
president took on the current
commander-in-chief I've known Joe over
the years he's not the brightest light
bulb in the group President Trump didn't
let up on Biden last night on Fox you
know coming on with some little cute
statements about made the way the world
is today well I'll tell you the way the
world is today is we have a strong
military he's not going to be able to do
the job earlier Thursday Biden smiled
for selfies but this is as close as our
cameras could get to the candidates
first fundraiser at the home of a
wealthy Comcast executive several
twenty20 Democratic candidates who've
relied on small donors responded with
their own requests for just three or
five dollars but Biden now needs to
raise more than $70,000 every day for
the rest of the year
just to catch up to the more than 18
million dollars Bernie Sanders brought
in by April with an average donation of
just $20 okay Joe Biden as part of his
strategy Biden branched out with this ad
in Spanish and unveiled a diverse staff
including Olympic figure skating
medalist Michelle Kwan but one part of
my dihn's past is once again in the
spotlight his campaign confirmed he
spoke recently with Anita Hill who says
Biden never apologized for his handling
of her accusations of sexual harassment
in 1991 against now Supreme Court
Justice Clarence Thomas Hill told the
New York Times Biden reached out
directly but stopped short of
apologizing for her treatment at the
Thomas hearing that
but she said Biden's actions do not
disqualify him and Biden insists he
didn't seek the support of his old
former running I asked President Obama
not to endorse whoever wins his
nomination should win it on their own
merits the former vice president is
headed back out on the trail by heading
out into his comfort zone he'll hold his
first campaign rally at a union hall in
Pittsburgh on Monday he and President
Obama won Pennsylvania twice but the key
state backed president Trump in the last
election Nora all right Edie thank you